you'll notice listen to this cnn
headline tell me if anything sounds
strange to you
biden has signed 42 executive actions
since taking office
here's what each one does
now one thing you might notice about
this is it's not wailing and gnashing
their teeth and saying these are
terrible executive actions and here's
how awful they are right which is what
you would see
if trump had done it but even just the
language
executive action that's kind of a new
phrase we haven't heard that very much
in the past but it's bubbling up a lot
now under the
under the biden administration you see
when when trump would sign these very
same things they were executive orders
telling you what to do forcing it down
your that's order awful
bad when biden does it it's an executive
action
action good we want action like an
action hero
oh yeah i like action because joe biden
we all know is so full of energy right
he's so with it he's got a lot of action
in him
now biden to his credit is not using
this kind of uh
rhetorical sleight of hand he's coming
out and saying yeah i'm signing a whole
lot of executive orders
and here's what they are but today i'm
about to sign two executive orders and
basically the best way to describe them
to undo the damage trump has done
there's nothing new that we're doing
here other than restoring the affordable
care act
and restoring the medicaid
to the way it was before trump became
president which by fiat
he changed made more inaccessible
more expensive and more difficult for
people to qualify
for either of those two items affordable
care act
or medicaid and the second uh
the second order i'm going to be signing
also
changes what the president has done
president of the president
what former president has done and that
a memorandum reversed the my
predecessor's attack on women's health
human health access and
as we continue to battle cover 19.
we could spend probably three hours just
talking about that train wreck of an
announcement because there was so much
in there
an apparent freudian slip where biden
referred to trump as the president
what is that what does that say what
does that tell you about joe biden's
mental state and what he
what he thinks about the state of the
country then
he goes and says that we've got to help
women's health and we're going to
restore women's health
and that's just a politically correct
euphemism that means abortion
so through executive fiat he's going to
restore
some of the funding for abortion and
some of the access to abortion
that trump took away meanwhile framed
right behind biden is a photo of him
meeting the pope
how how disgusting is this that joe
biden
a putative catholic sitting right next
to a very
intentionally placed photo of him
meeting the pope talks about how he's
going to
restore the butcher of innocent babies
around the country so
one of one of the most genuinely wicked
things i've seen a president
do so casually uh in in my lifetime
and and earlier even you know even even
looking back through history
then biden attacks donald trump
for all of these changes he had made by
fiat he said trump did it by fiat
so i'm gonna i'm gonna restore it
biden is also restoring it by fiat it's
doing the same thing they're both
they both were signing executive orders
it's just that even the procedure of
trump
wreaking these changes through executive
order is illegitimate compared to biden
when biden does it through executive
order totally
hunky-dory it's not even a change what
biden begins by saying is he says
look i'm not there's nothing new here
nothing new here folks i'm just
returning this all back to normal
you see i i had instituted i
with barack obama had instituted the
liberal policy which is obviously
what we should have that's normal in
this country and then trump
this guy had the audacity to get elected
and use the
his constitutionally prescribed
executive orders and you know the very
thing that i'm using right now he had
the audacity to do that and that's wrong
and
abnormal and so now when i switch that
back
it's just a return to normalcy nothing
new here of course it is new
when you change the policy of the
previous administration that
is something new but he's saying no
what he's what he's very subtly saying
here is
liberal policy is permissible
conservative policy is not legitimate
you used to hear people would talk about
the alt-right
you know look we like conservatives but
the alt-right they're the
they're the bad ones and i guess for a
while there was a distinction the whole
reason that there was the term alt-right
is because some people were saying i we
are an alternative to
more mainstream conservative thought but
now
very quickly that term just painted over
all right wingers
and now it's it's disappeared entirely
you don't hear the term anymore because
what the the left is doing is
delegitimizing the entire right
even the duly elected
center-right president donald trump
if you enjoyed that break from
disinformation historical revision
and screaming about the end of the world
be sure to hit the subscribe button
so that you never miss another video